it has been touted
as a key plank in the belton road
initiative
a high-speed railway linking thailand
with the rest of asean
a game changer for the entire southeast
asian region
but is the project moving fast enough
the disappointment with the current
state of affairs
reflects the fact that this government
tends to treat this project as a
domestic project
and in cambodia a high-stakes game that
has transformed a sleepy beach town
into a casino resort city
[Music]
alongside one of the largest special
economic zones in indochina
it seeks to make syrian oakville the
shenzhen of cambodia
with the target of eventually hosting
300 factories
and 100 000 industrial workers
from mega infrastructure projects to
spectacular chinese casino resorts
and massive industrial parks
china's belton road initiative is being
celebrated
but also causing discontent among locals
for us local is very very hard to get
the job
so people are very very sad
in this episode i visit cambodia an
enthusiastic participant
in china's one belt one road plan and
later i'll be heading over to thailand
which has seen a surge in chinese
investments in recent years
i began my quest to examine the impact
of china's new silk road
in cambodia in the heart of the nation's
capital phnom penh
here is one of cambodia's most important
national monuments
a statue of the late king noradom
sihanouk
[Applause]
the chinese tourists who visit this
place every day are reminded of the
critical role
that china played in cambodia's recent
history
king sihanook was cambodia's top
diplomat to china
and a lifelong friend to beijing he even
died in a hospital in china's capital
city
in 2012. in his lifetime king sehanuk
also enjoyed close friendships with
chinese leaders
including joe inlai who granted him
political asylum
and a place to stay in beijing when he
was deposed and exiled from his country
this is a testament to the historic
relationship between china and cambodia
which is still strong today
after that brief cultural segment many
chinese tourists head off to another
cambodian city
zehanukville is as you guessed it also a
tribute to the country's revered late
king
but it's less known for monuments or
temples or shrines
it's known for this
[Music]
in sihanoukville as far as tourism goes
the casinos
take center stage it's illegal for
locals to gamble in cambodia
but the 30 odd casinos here in
sihanoukville a port city 250 kilometers
away from phnom penh
is being transformed by chinese money
into a resort hub
the casinos are luring thousands of
chinese tourists
to sehenokville every month the industry
has proved so
lucrative that 70 more casinos are
currently being built
[Music]
i visit jinbe hotel and casino one of
the city's newest
the jinn bay opened just a year ago
with 30 tables and a staff strength of
560
95 of which are local it is currently
the largest casino
in sihanoukville
it's run by benson tan who is formerly a
director in singapore's marina bay sands
before being hired by jinbei's parent
company to launch
this casino in sianokville
[Music]
why see hanukkville why was this
location chosen
to set up casinos and hotels about
50 casino license has been issued
in xilang view and
[Music]
the government has planned to develop
this place into a mini macau
the chinese government took the leading
role
in the cambodia infrastructure
investment without that initiative
i believe that the sihana view city
economic growth
will be separate by another five to ten
years
okay for example the proposed the
expressway from
phnom penh cyanoview expressway will
shorten the travelling time from
phnom penh airport to shianoville to one
and a half hour
this will bring millions of visitors
from
international and nomping city to the
siyanovi
by then i think a lot we can attract a
lot of
international player to this location
casinos here in cambodia have
traditionally been associated with
corruption
and even links to the mafia how
are you going to ensure that
your casino is able to maintain an
international standard
and potentially not be associated with
this kind of
activity we have to start with the
senior management many casinos
the ceo is hired by the owner
or the owners shareholders uh
related people they will run the way
to the uh according to the owner's
wishes
okay but our company is different
we are here to build a brand to build a
reputation
so that's why we follow strictly
international casino standard and
procedure
so all the equipment we purchase are
from the approved
gaming supplier same standard as an
international casino
and our process are following singapore
and macau
procedure to ensure a fair game to the
players the chinese casino boom has
attracted more than just gamblers to
xihanukkil
it has also become a magnet for
employment in the city
attracted by the generous salary and
bonus packages offered by casinos like
jinbei
many locals have moved to sianukville
from the country's rural heartlands
it's transformed the one sleepy beach
town into a massive
urban sprawl
hui lang is one of those who decided to
seek his fortunes
in this cambodian boom town and the
mandarin classes he took in high school
helped greatly
how do you feel working here do you feel
this is a an opportunity
or you have many benefits working here
at the casino
well actually
[Music]
casino industry has created jobs for the
local community
i can't help but wonder about the
repercussions of fitting more than a
hundred casinos
in a city which is just one-tenth the
size of singapore
which in contrast only has two casinos
there are currently some 30-yard casinos
here in seahanekville
and there are plans to build 70 more so
how does your casino stay competitive
competition is uh inevitable so
and the biggest the casino
and the more offering of of the casino
will attract more players
okay so the trend is towards in
singapore style or macau style
integrated resort casino
so our group plan to build an integrated
resort
casino expected to be competed in three
or four year time
but outside the casino walls local
businesses
are struggling to stay in the game many
cambodians are being evicted from their
shops
because landlords are leasing properties
to chinese businessmen
who can afford to pay five times more
for the cost of rent
and to make matters worse local
businesses have also lost their
traditional customer base
western tourists who used to flock here
for the sea
sand and sun
[Music]
sahanakville is famous for its
never-ending string of beaches along its
coastline
and it used to be a hot spot for western
backpackers
but that's now a thing of the past the
recent influx of chinese tourists
has driven hotel prices almost triple
what they once were before
so now travelers with lower budgets have
stopped coming here
and that has had a profound impact on
local shops
and restaurants
[Music]
vote used to run one of the most popular
restaurants in seahanockville
two years ago
today it is empty
vut blames the chinese western people
very few i mean very very few and how
they don't come
anymore why is that yeah because uh
chinese take over so they raise the
pride up for
renting the room so why do you think
that the chinese expats
don't come to eat at your restaurant
chinese they always go to chinese
restaurant
stranger they eat there so all income
they want
to give back to the chinese people
vut's case seems clear from scenes just
across the road
this is one of many chinese eateries in
a town
[Music]
um
in this high-stakes game there are
winners
and losers
professor may kalyan a renowned academic
and an economic advisor to the cambodian
government
shares with me his personal views that
the government is still getting up to
speed
with this problem i
don't know the measure to be taken but
i'm sure if necessary you know and
everywhere
the government had to take action in
order to to maintain stabilities
the price of hotel go high people could
not go there anymore
many cambodians feel that it is our
countries but we feel like
we go to foreign countries and things
like that i think it's not a good trend
i feel that the problem is speed and too
much concentration
whatever it is you know if it developed
too fast
it creates imbalance in a system and
then create some
anxiety some animosities some concern
about local people
but we have to be careful also when
dealing with china where to be
because you know the relation with
cambodia and china
whereas we have also positive but we
have to work with the chinese government
how do we mitigate the negative aspect
right
it's not difficult to understand why
cambodia cherishes
chinese investment in xianukil
the steady trickle of chinese money into
this port city
has swelled to an enormous tide
but the new money is transforming the
city into an investment hub
not just for casinos but also for
manufacturing
it's home to an expanding special
economic zone
that's widely hailed as a pillar of
sino-cambodian cooperation
from dense forests haunted by a history
of mass genocide during the dark days of
the khmer rouge
to a resort city sihanoukville
is going through monumental changes
brought about by chinese investment
the chinese are making a splash not just
in tourism
they've also opened the sihanukville
special economic zone
or ssez
a massive industrial park and one of the
largest of its kind
it spans over 1 100 hectares making it
one of the largest special economic
zones in
indochina
it's also located close to cambodia's
only deep water port
under the watchful eye of both the
chinese and cambodian governments
the ssez is rapidly growing
in addition to offices and residential
buildings
it also houses close to 100
chinese-owned factories
in industries such as textiles and
hardware manufacturing
it seeks to make cehanokville the
shenzhen of cambodia
with the target of eventually hosting
300 factories
and 100 000 industrial workers
hongdoh international is one of almost a
hundred chinese companies
who've set up operations in sihanukville
they may close for the likes of celio
mango and zara
and other international players it has a
850 strong workforce
and most are cambodians
what were the main attractions for your
company to set up its operations
here in the sscz
um
what benefits has the ssc brought to the
local community
uh
um
foreign
although cehanukville is the focal point
for chinese investment into cambodia
the flow of chinese money into the
country is a far cry from being
localized
beijing has pledged billions of dollars
worth of infrastructure projects
and in phnom penh there are
chinese-owned condominiums that are
being built
at a rapid rate
until recently phnom penh used to be a
low-rise city
now a construction boom funded by
chinese money
is rapidly altering the cityscape with
buildings pushing higher
into phnom penh skies
i meet with dr kim hyung president of
the cambodian valuers and estate agents
association
he shows me royal one a new property
managed by his company
kim tells me that the majority of the
apartments and offices here
have already been swept up by chinese
buyers
so how has the cambodian real estate
industry been responding
to this boom before chinese investors
come in
the price is very cheap but after
the chinese wasted they come they buy
the land they build control they set a
maprofit
the land price increased two to five
times within one years
so those who own land they get to be
defeated
from the chinese study happy how have
cambodian real estate agents
been responding to this boom
i can tell you i noticed that for 13
years
13 years ago if you realize that you
don't need to speak foreign languages
you don't need to know
how to use computer software but now the
market is different
if you work in real estate now you must
be qualified in foreign languages
english and chinese you must speak two
of them
english is for everyone communication
chinese club deal chinese
you make money
this belief that the chinese would lead
you to prosperity
is shared by the cambodian government
who staunchly supports
china's belt and road initiative
the alliance between the two countries
who recently celebrated 60 years of
relations
has never been stronger beijing recently
pledged over 7 billion u.s
dollars to finance projects in
electricity
as well as building new airports and
roads including a mega four-lane highway
to connect sihanukville with the
nation's capital
but it's not just money that china has
contributed to cambodia
when the united states and the european
union threatened to slap cambodia with
sanctions
over the arrests of its opposition
leader and the dissolution of his party
it was china that stood by its ally and
voiced support for cambodia's efforts
to maintain order it's very clear
a chinese assistant is very important
because we need stabilities and to help
us
otherwise we have problems so many
complex situations to make decisions
and american european a few countries
they only
pick up one element okay if you don't do
this sanction
or democracy you're not immigration so
why that
right so why extension all the time
why we have to vary uh the big
the big powers and pressure on us all
the time right
why lecturing all the time we destroyed
our countries we made our countries
miserable nothing and then
come to lecture us about democracies we
have to be mindful of this also but
sometimes we could not please everyone
some local media have already chosen
signs
a case in point is fresh news an
independent
online news platform whose mantra is to
be the first
to break the news the 2018 chinese new
year celebrations
marked a fresh start for the publication
it launched a mandarin edition as part
of a revamp
fresh news's co-founder and chief editor
lim chiavuta
tells me the platform now has 2.5
million subscribers
which include chinese government
officials expats and businessmen
why did you decide to come up with a
mandarin edition
besides the potential advertising
revenue lim
is a fervent believer in china's new
silk road plan
fresh news is known for promoting china
its policies
and its investments
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this journey to cambodia has given me a
lot to reflect on
i've realized like in any business
partnership both sides have their own
set of vested interests
for china this developing nation offers
rapid economic growth
and good returns on investment cambodia
on the other hand
is eager to develop its economy without
the human rights demands from the west
through their various collaborations
both countries
have found that their interests are
indeed aligned
but it is a more complicated story in
neighboring thailand
asean's second largest economy has been
far more reticent
about china's one belt one road plan
[Music]
i'm in bangkok the capital of thailand
home to one of the world's largest
chinese minorities
a gateway to southeast asia's 600
million consumers
and more recently it has become a hot
investment destination for china
but for me personally this trip marks a
homecoming
i grew up in this country my family
moved here when i was three
and i lived in chiang mai until i was
18.
more recently my wife and i lived and
worked in bangkok for two years
so i have a strong personal connection
to this country
with its majestic temples vibrant
markets
bustling cities and most importantly its
people
i'm interested to find out how
thailand's recent engagements with china
is transforming a country that brings
back so many memories
[Music]
make a trip to bangkok's old town any
day and you'll see
large groups of chinese tourists making
their way to attractions
such as the royal palace and wat po
temple
the chinese make up the largest group of
visitors to thailand
every month
i meet with pontiff hirunkat vice
president of the association of thai
travel agents
to learn about the impact of the massive
influx of chinese tourists on the
country
what has been the average thai's
response
to this rather large number
of chinese tourists in the country i
have to say that you know
frankly first it was there's some
resentment
from from local people because they
never used
to have this many chinese tourists
gradually now
they realize and because the chinese
they do spend and i think they really
help our economy
according to pawn tips statistics each
chinese tourist
spends an average of 3 000 u.s dollars
per trip
eager to grab a share of all that
chinese spending many thai businesses
are transforming their business models
the rom 100 complex is a cultural theme
park
a one-stop destination where tourists
could get a taste of thailand
complete with the archetypes
mangoes floating market and
ladyboys
with your business here what kind of
experience do you aim to give
to the chinese tourists
but in an attempt to make this place
more chinese friendly
some cultural elements had to be tweaked
a little
instead of nagas and elephants a large
fortune cat greets me
at the entrance of the park
and the daily cabaret performances held
here feature performers
in mystical chinese costumes
[Applause]
images of mao zedong and tiananmen
square are looped in the background
as they lip-sync to mandarin ballads
[Music]
despite asamon's best efforts to woo
visitors
he is actually struggling to keep this
park running
this artificial lake at the end of the
park was once filled with boats
selling local produce it also used to
serve as a venue for the annual songkran
or
water festival celebrations but asimon
was forced to close this section of the
park
due to the declining number of visitors
which has dropped by more than half
compared to two years ago he tells me
that he has lost most of his business
to a rival establishment run by a
chinese company
the tour company which has affected
asamon's business
engages in a controversial practice
known
as zero dollar tourism
this is how the zero dollar tours work
first
a travel company in china sells insanely
cheap tour packages
to unsuspecting buyers when these
chinese tourists arrive in thailand
they're not brought to the usual tourist
attractions such as temples and markets
instead they are taken to restaurants
and souvenir shops
which are all partially owned by
companies based in china
and then they are prevented from
exploring the country on their own
by their chinese tour guide who forces
them to go
shopping instead of sightseeing
the main problem that thais have with
these tours is the fact that the revenue
generated
goes back to china at the expense of
local tour guides
shops and restaurants the tours also
avoid local taxes
depriving the thai treasury of millions
of dollars
um
the government that both thai and
chinese government
realize it and they have uh bring it to
a stop
and then and it's improved now
zero dollar tours haven't completely
gone away
but regular government crackdowns offers
some hope
that they'll be a thing of the past
and ties are still warmly welcoming
chinese visitors
to the country
some are even going a step further by
learning mandarin to help them serve
this growing market
[Music]
others are pushing their children to
pick up the language
and pick up the language they have very
quickly
[Music]
complete with polished accents and crisp
pronunciations
these students sound like beijing
natives but they
are thai concordian international
a private school in bangkok prides
itself for being one of the first
schools
in the country to integrate mandarin
into its curriculum
here students spend a third of their
school day learning mandarin
from kindergarten all the way through
high school
so why chinese though i mean you could
have gone with the option of german or
french or spanish
but why did you decide to found your
school
on teaching chinese as i travel around
anywhere in the world
it's almost everything every place i go
i pick up a product
everything made in china and i realized
that
you know how how how important it is
going to be
and i also see that many people trying
to come to business in china if they
don't speak the language
it's actually difficult very difficult
knowing their language and understanding
the culture
is really helpful to deal with business
[Music]
it's not just the language that students
in concordia are exposed to
but chinese politics and socio-economic
issues as well
the school even has classes specially
dedicated to discussing china's one belt
um
i see so you guys are actually studying
about the one belt one road
policy in your class very impressive wow
can you talk about why your school um
covers
topics like china's one belt one road
because this is
actually quite a complex issue that even
adults
find challenging so why is it that you
feel it's important
to feature here in your school the one
belgium road is going to have a major
effect in thailand and maybe the whole
asean
we want the kid to have a positive view
about a possibility of what could happen
between thailand
and china and the rest of the world
the growing number of thai schools
offering mandarin lessons
reflects a belief that thailand's
economic future
rests with its engagement with china
this view is shared by former thai prime
minister opposite vegeta
a strong proponent of china's belt and
road initiative
overall what benefits do you think
china's new silk road
will provide for thailand and for the
rest of asean
well infrastructure investment is needed
here in the country
and the fact that we want to build
an asean community an economic community
and the idea that we should be the
center of indochina
i think can benefit from the new silk
road
initiative we also believe that with
these
investments there will be more
opportunities for rural people in
thailand
particularly uh maybe along the route
of these linkages especially in the
northeast
we also will have access to the huge
chinese market these are all clear
benefits
from a country that has seen investment
crimped by a decade of political turmoil
thailand has seen a surge of investment
in recent years
thanks to china but will the tangled
negotiations surrounding a mega railway
network
threaten to derail sino-thailand
relations
by pumping in an average of 30 billion
dollars a year
china has claimed the number two spot on
the list of the largest investors to
thailand
but about five years ago it was barely
in the top ten
this is what changed things
a military coup in 2014 which saw many
foreign investors
abandon asean's second largest economy
the chinese on the other hand saw an
opportunity
and since then they have long enjoyed
warm welcome
in a country still struggling to draw
investments
over the past few years china has
emerged as
the second largest investor in thailand
previously
it was barely in the top 10 list of
investors in thailand
why the sudden change and what
opportunities do you think that china
sees in thailand it just reflects the
growing
economic power of china and
secondly i i believe that it's also a
deliberate
policy of china to have become
much more outward looking and wanting to
play a much
greater role in regional and also even
in global terms
there's a feeling of affinity between
thai and chinese people
geographically we are
at the center of indochina
in the past five years many chinese
companies have set up manufacturing
operations in thailand
to get closer to the supply of raw
materials
i visit fangdi latex company a leading
producer of rubber mattresses and
pillows
its factory is located within a special
economic zone
in thailand's chonburi province
the company set up here for easy access
to rubber supplies
but that isn't the only reason there's
also the labor
fangdi's chinese owner sia ming ciao
staffs his entire factory floor with
thai workers
[Music]
flagship outlet in bangkok's huequang
district
a hub for a very different sort of
business from what it used to be
in the old days i'm told
used to be a popular red light district
but in just two years
since chinese shops start opening here
it's come to be known as
new chinatown ming xiao tells me that
hundreds of chinese expats and tourists
visit this outlet every month
[Music]
china's export of technology to thailand
has extended beyond manufacturing
into key areas such as transport
the two countries are collaborating to
build a high-speed railway network
which would allow high-speed trains to
travel from kunming
in southern china to malaysia via thai
cities such as
nankai nikon rachisima and bangkok
it was former thai prime minister
opposite vajiva
who touted the high-speed rail network
as a game changer for the entire
southeast asian region
more than six years ago he's still
just as optimistic of the project's
potential
could you take a moment to share about
the importance
of the high-speed railway project for
thailand
and if realized how will this help
thailand
well ultimately we'd like to see this go
all the way to singapore
and you know asean has
made numerous studies
about how we want to have a seamless
or a connected region um
this can only become a reality if these
projects these kinds of projects are
completed it will help
uh you know make the benefits
of the free trade agreements or
economic partnership agreements concrete
because you know you can reduce tariffs
you can have all kinds of agreements but
if there is no
facilitation in terms of moving goods
and services across the border
then these agreements would not amount
to much
so i think it will contribute to
a stronger asean economy
but the reality is work on the
high-speed rail project
is moving much slower than everyone had
hoped
thai and chinese leaders have signed
agreements and attended
groundbreaking events together but the
fact is
they still haven't reached a conclusive
deal
the high-speed rail was unveiled in 2014
and since then the project has been
dogged by repeated delays
over loans financing as well as labor
and environmental regulations
a lot of thai engineer they have
considered
either long long project and it costs a
lot of money
it doesn't work we have already you know
we already have a railway connecting
between
thailand and laos and and and china you
know
going to construct a railway from
kunming to lao
so we are really connected you see there
is no need for a high-speed
thailand's high-speed railway network
was originally supposed to start in
nankai
which shares a border with laos it would
then
pass through nikon ratchasima to bangkok
however only the 250 kilometer line
between nakhon ratchasima and bangkok is
now slated for construction
without the crucial link between laos
and bangkok
china's plan of connecting yunnan with
thailand through a high-speed railway
is effectively stalled
analysts who are eager to see the
project get up to speed
blame the derailment on a mixture of bad
timing
and a lack of political will
first is that you know the president
government
came to power by coup d'etat so they are
quite reluctant
you know to initiate some big thing if
we wait until we have a legitimate
government that elected by general
election
maybe they are they they won't hesitate
they are more willing to make a big
decision
you know for this for the big project
like like when they were lost
the disappointment with the current
state of affairs
reflects the fact that this government
tends to treat this project as a
domestic project
i think if we put this in a regional
perspective
with a government that has a
strong political will to pursue this
and also to think in the longer term
about connecting up to all the
neighboring countries
then i think this project will be will
be given a new life
i conclude my trip to thailand with a
cruise down the chao piya river
which runs through the heart of bangkok
all the way
into the gulf of thailand
sailing down this river gives me the
chance to explore the city
without getting stuck in the massive
traffic jams that bangkok is notorious
for
and uh apart from several new
condominiums and
office buildings that have popped up i
haven't noticed
that many major changes compared to a
few years ago
the reality is that compared to cambodia
where signs of chinese investment
and joint infrastructure projects are
hard to miss
there is less demand for infrastructure
in asean's second largest economy
which is fairly developed
the current thai government is also
cautious about committing to long-term
infrastructure deals
with any country
but with the general election looming
many ties remain
optimistic that projects such as the
mega high-speed railway
might be put back on track under the
next government
in the meantime it's full speed ahead
for china
as it continues to expand its political
and economic influence
and strengthen relations with countries
across
asean through its one belt one road
infrastructure plan
you